hello again welcome to another episode
of community questions that i'm allowed
to host i've decided to move the format
around a little bit all these questions
are in some way about regularization
techniques so instead of going through
them rather randomly i'll try to explain
things a bit more oddly feel free to
skip to either part using the timestamps
below
so what is regularization and yes
everyone who writes it with a zed is a
bloody savage sorry leticia a
regularization is any technique that
helps your neural network to solve your
objective function in a better way
put simply your objective or loss
function tells your net what to do and
regularization is added to tell it how
it should do that as a simple example
consider fitting a function through
these given points
while the red curve does hit every
sample point it generalizes badly for
the samples not seen during training it
is overfitting
a regularization term here could enforce
smoothness giving you that nice green
curve that you can see
usually these regularizations are added
as an extra term to the loss function
so two very common regularizations that
are already built in in most optimizers
such as atom would be l1 and taken off
regularization that is also known as l2
or weight decay l1 regularization just
adds the absolute sum of all weights of
the network to the loss term whereas
ticking off or l2 regularization does
the same for the squared weights in
practice that just means that l1 does
not care which weights we actually touch
as long as we are always getting lower
in total for l2 regularization this
changes as we square each weight this is
always punishing the highest weight the
most
so while l2 regularization and tknoff
mean the same l2 regularization shrinks
the weights more evenly than l1
preferring to punish the higher weights
more than the lower ones and l2 does
this in a linear way always just
preferring to get the total sum of the
weights down if we reconsider our
example from the beginning we can easily
see why having either regularization
term is helpful to form a curve such as
the red line we'd need much higher
weights very informally spoken please
don't hit me for that sharper turns of
the output function require larger
weights whereas for example a flat line
can be produced just with all weights
being zero so this also helps against
overfitting while improving
generalization by preferring the green
over the red line
easy solutions just tend to generalize
better than memorizing every last bit of
the training data
now let's look at one regularization for
the analysis lovers
let's quickly repeat what lipschitz
continuity is and see how we can use
that to for example better train guns or
defend against adversarial attacks
a function is lip shit's continuous with
the lipstick's constant c if a change
applied to its input value never changes
the output value by more than c times
that input change or with other words
there is some upper limit to the slope
of this function
as our networks are also just piecewise
linear functions we can also compute the
lipschitz constant for them discretely
spoken this means that for any two
samples of the input their output
distance relative to the input distance
should at most be that lipschitz
constant meaning for a network that is
lipschitz continuous when we fiddle
around with one single input the output
change occurring has some upper bound
and that is already the answer to this
question
a simple way of enforcing lipschitz
continuity is the so-called weight
clipping the output of a network always
depends on its weights and when we
simply set an upper limit to the
absolute value of a weight that is we
just clip any weight that is larger than
this limit we already obtain a very
crude limit on how much the change in
the input can change the output leaving
us with a lipschitz bound it's just the
same argument as before for the l1 and
l2 regularization high slope needs
higher values as coefficient meaning
high weights in the network
and by enforcing that our weights are
small we make sure that the learned
function does not have any of these
sharp turns that we do not want
now let's have a look at what else this
is good for imagine that you want to
train a gun and i'm explicitly saying
imagine here because these things are a
pain to drain
so you train your gun and during
training your discriminator becomes way
too good for the generator that means
that you suddenly have a strong jump in
your discriminator and meaning that when
your generator is producing superfake
outputs slightly changing something as
you'd usually do when training networks
won't help at all your output will still
be very much fake
hence you basically end up with a
vanishing gradient problem there is just
no clear direction in which your
gradient points that can help you you'd
need to change a whole lot of things and
then suddenly the discriminator gets to
this jump and thinks your generated
output is real
and this of course means that you can't
properly train your generator anymore
big problem lots of headache
so what do you do about that well you
don't want these jumps in your loss
function you want your loss function to
smoothly change with a limited rate of
change which is exactly what a lipschitz
bound for your network does so for
example you enforce lipshit's continuity
through weight clipping and boom things
get better
mostly
sometimes guns are lots of fun now
before you run off and use that
knowledge don't because there is an even
better regularization technique
lipschitz continuity prevents you from
having steep changes in the loss but it
does not prevent local optima or the
function changing only slowly or not at
all much better than that we can simply
say that our network should not be
lipschitz bound but instead also exactly
change by some constant relative to the
input change meaning our regularization
term is just enforcing a constant
gradient for example one everywhere
which in theory means that there is no
local optimum anymore a function into a
network with a constant gradient like
one everywhere has not one spot where
the gradient is zero it is just some
linear function and as we all know a
local optimum has always a gradient of
zero and on such a linear function we
can train even better lastly lipschitz
regularization can also help us against
adversarial attacks
for adversarial attacks we usually look
for a tiny shift in the input that
causes a large shift in the output for
example when we add almost invisible
noise perturbations to this image of a
panda we can make it look like a given
to a classifier that we trained before
well if only there was such a thing to
make sure these tiny input changes do
not totally change the output well again
lipschitz regularization to the rescue
enforcing a somewhat low lipschitz
constant for the network means that for
an input that is only slightly changed
we cannot change the output by much or
in other words we need to shift a lot
more pixels much more visibly to change
this panda into a gibbon in the eyes of
our classifier
so i hope that this was somewhat useful
to you as always i would be very happy
for some feedback in the comments and
we'll leave you some additional links
and sources in the comments bye bye